[Applause]
thank you and i
uh first of all
i'm sorry i missed the last two weeks
i didn't want to you heard this they
said i had uh coveted uh
this is you know it's like when you go
to jiffy lube they
show you the air filter and they go okay
okay you're the expert all right
i i you know i thank you for all the get
well wishes i can't oblige you i never
was sick
i felt nothing but okay you know i mean
i had the vaccine that's another rumor i
know i had it you know i mean who knows
it's not
not worthy of applause but okay you know
did it help with probably i don't know
we don't we don't know yes probably i
don't know
i you know most people who got the thing
never you know got very sick
less than four percent went to the
hospital i know media doesn't like to
talk about that
it's something to be respected obviously
yes and i'm so good
the point is i had it
and now in america we're like bribing
people to get the vaccine
really i mean they're giving away like
college scholarships and free beer and
baseball tickets because california's
giving away 116 million dollars in cash
and prizes
[Applause]
we're
we're at the bob barker phase of the
pandemic
i love this country all over the world
people are dying to get this vaccine
but here they got to give you a jet ski
first and then maybe i will consider
the other stupid thing people said how
could you have you know tested positive
if you had the vacci it happens
they never said it was 100 effect nobody
ever did the same week happened to me
nine yankees
who had the vaccine tested positive
which is
supporting my theory that the virus
comes from bats
no that's
that's that's not even my theory i was
always saying from the beginning
it could have been lab it could have
been bats
facebook said you can't even say it
might be in the lab well now everyone's
saying it might be
i was always saying this is not
political just treat this as a science
issue we don't know where it came from
well now the wall street journal says it
might be the lab
we have the guy from former cdc heads
that
he thinks it's the lab we don't know the
biden administration now is
looking into it might be the lab and
there are rumors and i'm not saying it's
nefarious in the lab just an accident
but there are rumors that maybe the lab
was manipulating the virus
to make it stronger which is a violation
of a sacred principle in china
no substitutions and
you can
try to pretend that's a racist joke good
luck with that i don't care
it's not
you